an international response to an
international disaster Qatar one of
turkey's closest allies has opened an
air bridge to deliver Aid
the humanitarian Aid which exceeded a
hundred tons contained tents Food
Supplies blankets and cleaning
detergents for the affected people
they're also adding manpower to rescue
efforts and this military plane is
flying straight into the earthquake's
epicenter gazientep
we're on our way to Turkey on a relief
flight that is transporting ruttering
military personnel to the country to set
up a base there and help with emergency
response
turkey's president erdogan made an
international appeal soon after disaster
struck and said 70 countries pledged to
help
we declare the ten provinces beset by
the earthquakes to be a disaster area
affecting General Life by the power
conferred on us by article 119 of the
Constitution we have decided to declare
a state of emergency support is now
flooding in from all over the world from
Britain and France to South Korea and
Russia
but freezing temperatures and
aftershocks have made this an endless
nightmare with buildings crumbling into
streets and many still buried under
Rubble
International solidarity is key to
addressing this catastrophe but in
practice or only scratch the surface
Sky News gazian tap